hey Luke here with the outdoor boys
YouTube channel I'm going to show you
how to tie one of the most versatile
knots around the Alpine butterfly
[Music]
the Alpine butterfly loop is a great
knot for putting a secure loop in the
middle of a rope it's an alternative to
the figure-eight loop knot or the
surgeon's loop and one of the benefits
of this is that it doesn't collapse
under great pressure it's a very secure
strong knot additionally it's really
easy to undo which is always great when
you're putting knots and valuable rope
the Alpine butterfly loop has a close
cousin called the Alpine butterfly Bend
which is for attaching two pieces of
rope together it's a main advantage is
that it's a lot easier to undo then like
the fisherman's bend or the water knot
so I'm gonna show you how to tie the
Alpine butterfly loop the Alpine
butterfly Bend
additionally the Alpine butterfly loop
there's three different methods for
tying this knot there's the twist method
and there's two different versions of
the hand method each one kind of has its
pros and cons and some people find one
method easier to learn than the other so
I'm going to show you all three methods
and you can figure out which one works
best for you additionally I'm gonna show
you some great applications for this
very versatile knot and you take a loop
and you twist twist and then you fold
the twists over and spread it apart and
feed it through
and then dress it there you go
okay so let me show you one more time a
little bit slower take this loop twist
twist then go ahead and flip it under
spread the loop apart pull this part
through and that's it
and this is what it looks like should be
nice even right here symmetrical here
and then criss-crossed there and they
call it the Alpine butterfly because it
kind of looks like this little butterfly
pattern alright let me show you the hand
method for tying the Alpine butterfly
loop you wrap the rope three times
around your hand you reach under grab
the middle strand pull it out a little
bit pull it over the other two strands
under and out forming a loop and that's
it grab the two tag ends pull them tight
and then simply dress the knot so that
you get that symmetrical butterfly
pattern that you're looking for it's as
simple as that this is a great method
when your fingers are cold when you're
in a hurry I think this is the simplest
method the second hand method has you
pulling the rope across your palm and
forming a loop on your fingertips and an
X on your palm you take the loop on your
fingertips you pull it down and out then
tuck it under the X and pull it up and
out forming your loop you pull the tag
ends and dress you're not the biggest
advantage of this method is it's very
similar to how you tie the Alpine
butterfly Bend when it comes time to
undo the Alpine butterfly loop it's
really easy to undo no matter how tight
the knots been simply take the tag ins
like this push the loops around and then
pop the Alpine butterfly loop is great
for making pulley systems for making
mechanical advantages and for making
loops that you can get back without
having to climb up a tree alright let me
show you one of the great uses for the
Alpine butterfly loop it's great when
you want to attach your rope to
something and then not have to go back
to retrieve it so let's say you attach
your rope up to a limb on the top of a
tree you don't have to climb up the tree
to get your rope back so let me show you
how to do it so once I've made my Alpine
butterfly loop I take the tag end of the
rope throw it around whatever I want to
secure beat it back through the loop and
then pull it
there we go nice and solid and whenever
I want my robe back I grab the working
end and out it comes
so I attach one end of the line to what
I want to pull one end of the line to an
anchor I put in an Alpine butterfly loop
feed the tag end through and now we've
got a two-to-one mechanical advantage
the Alpine butterfly loop is really good
for making points to attach to
carabiners
or for creating handholds and ropes all
right let me show you the Alpine
butterfly Bend it's almost exactly the
same knot but instead it's used to
attach two different ropes together in a
way that you can get apart and if you
look at the knot it looks just like the
Alpine butterfly loop when it's all
dressed up it looks the same so let me
show you how to tie it okay now let me
show you the Alpine butterfly Bend this
looks a lot more complicated than it
really is it is just two interlocking
overhand knots take the first red rope
store it in your fingers and take the
blue rope around your hand
back under your palm and under the red
rope forming an overhand knot then get
yourself some slack to work with and tie
another overhand knot only this one just
goes underneath the red rope and doesn't
go underneath the blue rope then you
grab both tag ends and both of the
working ends pull it tight dress the
knot and once dress the knot is exactly
the same as the Alpine butterfly loop
only you've attached to ropes and the
advantage of this knot is it's very easy
to get undone alright let me show you
how to get this knot apart pinch these
sides together push it down and out
comes the not even when it's super tight
you can get it undone we'll hopefully
enjoyed that video and learn something
new if you'd like to learn some more
great knots from the outdoor boys
youtube channel don't forget to check
out our other
eight knots that you need to know I'll
put a link in the description and don't
forget to click subscribe we put out new
videos every week thanks for watching